[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
trial for murder out of ohio we bring
you up to speed on trial of accused
arsonist stanley ford now stretching
into day eight in court ultimately at
the end of the day you're also not going
to convince people that
r kelly was a saint as the federal trial
against r kelly heats up law and crime
daily sits down with the singer's former
new york attorney who tells us why he
thinks the trial is right on track we're
talking about murder here and the
california trial of real estate air
robert durst continues as the
prosecution alleges durst killed his
best friend the defense pushes back in
their closing arguments but first a
bombshell out of the pike county
massacre as matriarch angela wagner
pleads guilty in her first court
appearance of 2021 law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to the season two
premiere of law and crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
a grandmother admits to her role in the
execution-style murders of eight members
of another family in the pike county
ohio
in april 2016 eight members of the
rodent and gilly families were shot to
death many as they slept with their
children by their sides more than two
years later four members of the wagner
family were indicted for the murders
earlier this year jake wagner pled
guilty and said he and his family
committed the murders so he could have
sole custody of the daughter he shared
with one of the victims hannah rhoden
law and crimes angela levy has covered
the case since day one and is here with
somewhat of a surprising development
anjanette
yeah it was a little bit of a surprise
brian you know this case rocked the
community in southern ohio when it
happened you had one family accused of
killing members of another family many
as they slept now we have two wagner
family members admitting guilt
officers wearing body armor guarded
angela wagner as she walked into a pike
county courtroom to admit after years of
denials that she helped plan the murders
of hannah rhoden and her family
charges of aggravated murder were
dropped against angela wagner she
pleaded guilty to a long list of other
counts including conspiracy to commit
aggravated murder aggravated burglary
and tampering with evidence prosecutors
say she didn't pull the trigger but knew
exactly what was going to happen the
night of the murders and help plan them
angela admitted to purchasing some items
leading up to the offenses that were
meant to help the other three
co-defendants in carrying out crimes
such as a phone jam jammer which
prevents people from being able to call
for help and the shoes that her two sons
wore during the homicides specifically
of the size and style that they would
not typically wear and also to finding
and printing off and forging custom
documents angela wagner and her son jake
have confirmed the prosecution's theory
that the motive for the murders was
custody of a daughter that jake wagner
shared with hannah rhoden that child was
with angela wagner the night of the
murders hannah rhoden was shot with her
newborn baby girl laying next to her
other children were with their parents
when they were shot
some are specific targets of the wagners
some sadly
were killed simply because they happened
to be there
angela wagner has agreed to tell all
during the trials of her son george and
husband billy in exchange she'll serve a
minimum of 30 years in prison she had
nothing to say as she left the
courthouse under heavy guard
angela do you have anything to say
there's been a lot of chatter on social
media people questioning why in the
world angela wagner would be given a
30-year sentence
we tried to get some information about
that from the prosecution they aren't
commenting because of a gag order but
the prosecution did say in court that
she provided information about other
crimes that the wagner family had
committed there weren't details about
what those crimes were so we're just
going to have to wait and see as time
goes on what comes out brian
thanks internet joining us today is
former federal prosecutor gene rossi and
terry austin gene first it was jake
wagner in april now it's angela should
we expect more of the wagner family to
start taking pleas as the evidence and
family witnesses grow against them
absolutely and the saddest thing is the
person who waits until the end to plead
guilty this is like a snowball starts
rolling down the hill he had jake now
the mother angela and uh she's
cooperating and to have uh the spouse
and the mother of two remaining
co-defendants testify
that is absolutely
devastating to those remaining
defendants so i predict there could be
one more pleading guilty and then the
last person uh
heaven forbid what's going to happen to
him yeah it's going to be like a fire
drill just people rushing to try to take
a plea because as you said you don't
want to be the last one that cooperates
because that's going to be a tough hill
to climb terry angel didn't pull a
trigger but she was a big part of the
planning these horrific murders just 30
years in exchange for testifying against
her family sound right to you
it actually does brian nothing no matter
how long she's in jail will bring back
these eight men women and children but
her pleading guilty and testifying
against her husband billy and her son
george is going to help the prosecution
they're going to spend less time less
money on those cases
and she's 50 years old so by the time
she even gets out it which she won't
she'll be 80 years old she doesn't have
a chance of parole so
i think that it is reasonable we know
that you know her son jake did plead
guilty he's got eight consecutive life
sentences so i think it's appropriate i
absolutely do absolutely and jeanette
with jake and angela green to testify
against george and billy wagner what's
the status of their cases
well george wagner was in court on
monday and the proceeding actually
didn't really go forward there was no
substance to that proceeding because
there wasn't a court reporter there
however um his attorneys just last
friday when that hearing happened for
angela wagner were given the confessions
the statements of both jake and angela
wagner so they haven't even had a chance
to review those items and i spoke uh by
email with billy wagner's attorneys he's
due in court later this week they still
have not received the statements of jake
and angela wagner so
they are just kind of in pre-trial mode
just waiting uh to get that information
and review it with their clients yeah i
think once they get that information
review of the clients we might see a
little bit more of what gene rossi was
suggesting down the line thank you all
and to more illegal news in the state of
ohio where a man is accused of setting
three fires in his neighborhood
stanley ford is on trial for the murders
of nine people including an entire
family by setting two houses on fire in
his ohio neighborhood he's also accused
of setting fire to a parked car where
nobody was harmed if convicted ford
could face the death penalty monday
marked day eight of the arson trial
where a forensic fire supervisor took
the stand to talk about what he found on
surveillance footage the night that one
of the fires was set we will continue to
follow the case and bring you the latest
on lawn crime daily
a judge sentenced an ohio mother to 21
years to life in prison for the murder
of her son brittany gosney admitted to
the murder of her six-year-old son james
hutchinson earlier this year gossip
admitted to trying to leave james and
his siblings at a park and when she
tried to leave she hit james with her
vehicle as he tried to grab the door
handle gossey said she and her boyfriend
james hamilton threw the boy's body in
the ohio river his body has never been
found hamilton will be sentenced next
month
l.a dodgers pitcher trevor bauer will
not return for the end of the season as
an investigation continues into
allegations he sexually assaulted a
woman bower has been on administrative
leave for months last month a judge
denied the accuser's request for a
permanent restraining order against
bauer the woman claimed bower left her
with serious injuries after rough sex
but bauer produced text messages that
showed the accuser said give me all the
pain la's district attorney is reviewing
the case to determine whether criminal
charges will be filed
still ahead on law and crime daily the
defense is ramping up their closing
arguments as a trial against robert
durst continues to unfold well the
defense says the state must prove to
receive a guilty verdict but first
updates on the federal trial against r b
singer r kelly we hear from r kelly's
former new york attorney what he says it
will take for the jury to clear the
singer
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube
you can now get the live law and crime
network with youtube tv for all of your
daily live trial coverage legal news
expert analysis and original true crime
programs subscribe to youtube tv today
and then locate lawn crime in the
channel guide and for only 1.99 a month
you can add the network to your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back now to a case we've been
following for weeks r kelly's sex
trafficking trial is back in session
kelly was charged in july 2019 after
years of claims that he sexually abused
women by way of his celebrity status
kelly's accusers say he used his staff
to recruit women and underage girls to
participate in illegal sexual activity
forcing them to follow a series of rules
including asking for permission to eat
or use the bathroom officials say the r
b singer violated the racketeer
influence and corrupt organizations law
otherwise known as the rico act kelly is
accused of sexual exploitation of minors
and transporting people across state
lines for prostitution
for more information about kelly's
defense we turn to attorney steve
greenberg who previously represented
kelly on the brooklyn federal case and
still represents the singer in his
illinois litigation i sat down with
greenberg for a one-on-one interview
where he reveals what he believes it
will take for the defense to win the
case
so let me just be clear you're kind of
taking a scalpel to this case and you're
saying sure
he may have spread herpes to the three
or four accusers who've been on the
stand so far sure some of these women
may have been underage even though they
lied about their age at the time but
you're going specifically to
where is the enterprise that's your
argument here that you think it's gonna
win the day
right well the i i think the only way to
win this case is to attack the
enterprise there have been a lot of
attacks on the women and are they
credible or are they not credible
uh you know why were they doing it they
wanted to be his girlfriends now when
everything comes out they're claiming
they were abused there's been a lot of
you know when you left you didn't
complain to anyone you didn't tell
anyone you didn't call the police and
all of that is is well and good because
you don't want the jurors to feel sorry
for these women if the jurors feel sorry
for the women
then they're more likely to give the
government a break on what's really the
meat of the case which is the rico
offense any level of concern
as to the case so far for r kelly or do
you think
so far in a pretty good place this is
where i anticipated where we would be at
this time
i i think the case has been going well
for r kelly i i haven't been reading the
transcripts so i can't tell everything
you know it's interesting you get
such competing views um when you look on
the internet from people that are r
kelly supporters who who think that
they're just killing it and and some of
the for lack of a better term mainstream
media when you read those accounts you
think that the case is problematic for
them although in both accounts there's
still these weaknesses in the ricoh case
i don't agree with the approach of some
of the attorneys i think that some of
the attorneys in the case smartly uh
have now been made to sit down because
they have no idea what they're doing do
you think that these 12 people that have
been selected
so far
are gonna carry the day for r kelly do
you think they're gonna lean more
towards the prosecution
well and and here's the problem for our
kelly in a rico case in order to prove
the rico they only need two
substantive acts to be proven
so
the jurors only have to agree that two
of them many many things i think there's
18 separate acts occurred they could
discount everything but for instance the
couple of man activations which are
really the easiest ones for the
government to prove and that's why you
have to attack the enterprise because
then you need all 12 people i think all
12 people are going to agree that
there's a couple of predicate acts but
then you need them to agree on the
existence of the enterprise but i don't
think that you're going to be able to
get 12 people to agree that there was in
fact an enterprise here
let's bring back former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
terry a former employee on the stand
from friday said that r kelly asked her
why she let the women escape could that
spell out rico against kelly
absolutely and the operable word here
brian is escape there are over a dozen
underlying acts for the ricoh charge and
one of them is kidnapping and forced
labor and if kelly himself used that
word escape it means he knows he's
holding people against their will he's
forcing them to do labor against their
will so her testimony was absolutely
critical here
gene i get the technical argument that
steve greenberg is is making here but it
begs the question what's the difference
between an enterprise for sex
trafficking and people working for
someone who happens to be a sexual
predator
well one is uh conspiracy uh i can
conspire with somebody say we had a
lemonade stand instead of lemonade we
sold moonshine and we're just using a
chair in front of a house and two or
three of us are selling moonshine that's
a conspiracy
what mr greenberg rightly says is uh
enterprise is much different it has an
infrastructure it can be formal or
informal and what he's saying is there's
no infrastructure uh by which these
crimes were committed that's a tough
road to hope given the predicate acts
that have been alleged all right well
gene you let me know where this lemonade
stand is we're definitely gonna check it
out later
thank you for that
still ahead on law and crime daily after
four months of back and forth closing
arguments are underway in the trial
against robert durst we'll hear from the
real estate airs defense first hand plus
big news out of wisconsin in connection
to the slenderman stabbings where a
defendant is headed after five years in
a state mental health institution
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
covering cases from coast to coast we
begin in wisconsin where a defendant in
the so-called slender man stabbing is
said to be released from a mental health
institution
nineteen-year-old anissa weir and morgan
geyser were convicted back in 2014 of
stabbing their middle school classmates
19 times all this they said was the name
of slenderman a fictional character that
appeared in fan fiction and video games
the girls lured then 14 year old payton
lightner into the woods stabbed her and
left her for dead lightner survived the
near deadly attack
in 2017 weir was found not guilty by
mental disease or defect and sentenced
to 25 years to life in july of this year
it was announced she would be released
under the stipulation that it should be
tracked by health services caseworkers
until age 37. authorities say wayer
plans to live with her father upon her
release
in california newly unsealed fbi
documents show the late kobe bryant
received an unsolicited murder for
higher offer in connection with a rape
accuser back in 2003 the nba star was
accused of rape by a woman out of
colorado new documents show then 31 year
old patrick garber a swiss bodybuilder
living in california reached out to
brian offering to kill the accuser in
exchange for three million dollars
according to the documents brian
contacted the fbi right away agents then
arranged a meeting with the grabber for
more information he was arrested in
september 2003 when he believed he would
receive the first million dollar payment
bryant maintained that the relations
with his accusers were consensual but
was charged with felony sexual assault
the charges were later dropped when the
accuser refused to testify
in international news prince andrew of
great britain has served with a federal
lawsuit set to go before a new york
judge on monday virginia drew frey says
the duke of york sexually assaulted her
three times when she was just 17 years
old drew frey one of the outspoken
victims of the late jeffrey epstein says
he and associate elaine maxwell coarced
her to have sexual relations with the
prince she also says two of the
incidents happened at epstein's property
drew frey filed a lawsuit against prince
andrew in the same jurisdiction as a
previous lawsuit against maxwell that
trial is scheduled for later this year
for his part the prince has repeatedly
denied the allegations
when we come back the state of
california vs robert durst after months
in session closing arguments are finally
upon us we bring you into the courtroom
to hear from the real estate air's
defense
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
defense closing arguments continue in
california for the trial of robert durst
durst is charged with the murder of his
best friend susan berman prosecutors say
durst killed berman because she knew
information about his wife kathy's
disappearance durst has been suspected
in her disappearance but her body has
never been found the four-month trial
started nearly a year and a half ago
halted by the pandemic endures failing
health closing arguments started last
wednesday after nearly three weeks of
testimony from durst himself day two of
the defense closing argument began with
david chestnut reminding the jury of
what he thinks to be the lack of
evidence shown by the prosecution
showing the guns from texas doesn't
prove bob had a gun in california
there's no evidence at all presented in
this five-month trial that bob possessed
a weapon that murdered susan berman in
california they showed you lots of guns
none tied to susan berman's murder they
showed you five guns i think
why'd they do that
same reason they showed you the
dismembered body parts
oh my god there's guns
you guys are way more sophisticated than
that
you're way more
responsible than that
you're way more intelligent than that
the defense then went on to remind the
jury everything that the state has to
prove including that durst murdered his
wife kathy and that berman was a witness
to that crime
here the prosecution didn't even
prove the alleged crime that susan was
supposed to be a witness
a witness to
they don't even have their theory
straight did kathy fall down the steps
or did bob kill her
i mean which one is it
nothing
we're talking about murder here they
want you to convict somebody for murder
without telling you
about the murder that the other person's
supposed to be a witness to improving
there was a murder
it can't happen
it can't happen
so susan wasn't a witness to anything
susan was simply a friend who cared for
bob
and eventually helped him as a
spokesperson
gene the defense argued that kathy used
cocaine and had trouble in med school
where's the defense trying to go with
these accusations
they're trying to uh defile the victim i
don't think it's a good strategy
i think the defense should just stick to
the lack of evidence
winshut
westchester county did not charge
mr durst with any murder for new york
didn't charge him with any murder and
now in l.a they're going to prove
there's a murder i think it's a very bad
strategy at the end of the day
they have to focus on the evidence that
ties susan berman's murder to robert
durst
forget kathy durst don't don't defile
her don't ruin her name agree that's a
bad strategy agreed terry both defense
attorneys talked about a lack of
evidence could this argument resonate
with the jury
actually i don't think at the end of the
day it will resonate with the jury i
agree with chestnut
the jury is sophisticated but they're
sophisticated enough to know you don't
have to have direct evidence
circumstantial evidence is good enough
and there's plenty here not to mention
the cadaver note and the fact that durst
was in la when susan berman was killed
so i think they have proven the case
against
durst all right we'll see how it plays
out just a few more to go in this case
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you